all right tonight the three and out
cowboys uh 12 days after their last game
they played on thanksgiving it feels
like it's been a very long time maybe it
has been just six days for the ravens
since their last game hosting dallas
let's do some prop bets chris a critical
game for the baltimore ravens lamar
jackson back from the covet 19 reserve
list passing yard over under
176.5 you got the over you got the under
i'm gonna take the i'm gonna take the
over i'm gonna go the over here i just
think that dallas is gonna have to sell
out in a way to stop the run that's just
gonna make things a little too
uncomfortable and just gonna lead to a
few opportunities of baltimore being
able to make a few throw big plays in
the pass game yeah i'll go over as well
and uh i i just think that there's going
to be an urgency tonight from the ravens
that we maybe haven't seen for a while
they know what they're up against they
know what they need to do and i think
they believe as we said earlier if they
get to the playoffs they can make some
noise next prop courtesy as all our of
points bet lamar jackson over under 50.5
rushing yards you got the over the other
on that over over over over i mean it
seems low it does seem low i mean
there's no doubt about it and
i mean what what would make you think
that dallas is gonna stop any type of
run game anyways i mean we've seen
washington running on them twice we saw
the even though the vikings when they
lost that game dalvin cook wasn't the
issue they ran the ball on them i mean i
would just think i i would think lamar
jackson in the run game uh have a pretty
successful night uh tonight for
baltimore
yeah i agree with you look i
i i don't i
the ravens
haven't been the ravens that we're used
to but they're still pretty damn good
and last week we saw a team that was a
shell
of what it could be and all the stuff
they dealt with with covet 19 one of the
points that rg3 made after the game
family members have gotten you know
they're dealing with all sorts of issues
and concerns and worries this was a
major outbreak of a very contagious
strain they had four different strains
of the virus in their building and one
was highly contagious and it ripped
through everything so they had a lot to
deal with and they still gave the
steelers you know a better game than
maybe we thought they would so yeah i i
think we're going to see a different
ravens team tonight and that's that's
bad news for the dallas cowboys more
rushing yards between the top two
tailbacks for tonight zeke elliott or jk
dobbins who has more that's a good one
there
that could be close because i mean again
the other the problem with baltimore is
you just don't know if it's going to be
jk dobbins that'll be the guy i mean gus
edwards could steal the show a little
bit also let me ask this
do we know calais campbell brandon
williams where they're at i tend to
honestly want to go jk dobbins here
regardless i don't really care
uh that much i don't have a lot of faith
zack barton not playing now i mean the
dallas o line is a shell of what it used
to be or could be
uh
and of course i would think baltimore
being the way they are they're gonna put
their corners on an island and say no
let's see if andy dalton and your
receivers can beat us they never let the
run game just beat them it's very rare
so i'm gonna go with jk dobbins i'm
going baltimore rushing extravaganza
tonight
calais campbell questionable with calf
injury brandon williams questionable
with ankle injury campbell came off of
the kova 19 reserve list recently so uh
we'll see all right there's a chance
usually usually though yeah questionable
yeah i don't i don't know what the
percentage rate is but
questionable gives them a pretty good
chance to play and we haven't seen them
for a while and they need campbell uh
the big picture and we we did this last
week in the mega pix podcast we both
made our picks for the game but uh let's
let's refresh it now dallas at baltimore
minus 7.5 is the current line raven's
the favorites who you got well i'm i
mean i'm going baltimore i'm trying to
i'm actually got to go back a few page
pages here i'm going wait who who the
hell did i pick in this one i mean by
the score i'm going back i have it all
the way 28-17 i got it i'm going
baltimore 28-17 i am i think like to
what you said first off i think
baltimore's gonna be pissed off ready to
go they're gonna even feel more
confident because they're gonna go hey
we're healthy and we got covered 19 guys
here and everything like that lamar's
back in the fold right and the the
playoffs are still very much in play for
them they know that i would think you're
going to see a pretty much an a or an
a-plus effort from the baltimore ravens
tonight
i picked 28 to 20 when we did it last
thursday and i'll stick with 28 to 20.
over under 45 and a half it looks like
we both have what's my math here my math
isn't good we both have
you've got i got the under five on the
you've got the under and i've got the
overall i've got 48. i can't count i
can't i once upon a time i was really
good at math i don't know what's
happened i have no excuse for it all
right how about dez bryant
even though he's irrelevant as matt
casey suggests i i still think that it's
intriguing because he gets a chance to
play the cowboys
30 or more receiving yards and one or
more touchdowns a plus 450 proposition
bet 100 win 450. would you take that bet
um
i don't think i would i like the plus 30
receiving yards i do think the baltimore
ravens will try to go out of their way a
little bit to have a play or two for dez
bryant coaches you know people usually
have a soft spot for guys like this and
knowing he's going against his old team
and if he's been a good soldier and
worked hard and we know he's had some
obstacles overcome i think they'll feed
the ball i think he gets over 30 yards
but i don't like the touchdown thing
though
i'll take it i'll take it i cause i
think they are going to find a way you
took it last week so here i'm taking it
again
again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports